yeah hello and welcome to this video
plane do I have a audio yeah playing
this Wow
that's a weird name that g AR h okay
okay he likes his fiance Rose isn't d5 a
good move here looks a bit awesome but
why the stern Queen takes mm any feeling
Kalos Queen takes Knight f3 f1 Knight c3
oh where are all those nights coming
okay I'm doing this like here I was
thinking to go queen h5 and he has to
move this night only three are no way
exactly I mean to weird square h4
okay I cannot go g5 that is too much on
the long diagonal now if if one okay if
all if for might become weak
yeah I have no really good way to cover
that I mean I can't operate with this
counter idea against each form okay
thank you
where'd you go you know maybe here
future Bishop d6 can be account to play
against the night I mean a five runs in
two runs in two other stuff we need have
a three before and so on okay okay
if four is under fire but I can't go
away five I'm a little bit behind
clockwise but it's not a huge issue I
think odd before it's weird I just what
is he going for him
am I not just winning in this pawn that
takes before what's the deal I don't get
it what is the trick Knight f6 rook f6
doesn't work nothing works in just win
stuff what's going on
[Music]
what is that all about
your route shakes
yeah what a weird game yeah okay let's
go I mean he sends me a rematch request
but I want to figure this out I mean it
really looks like a strange opening
I wonder if actually if aged five is the
right square the engine wants to go
Queen a five you know I think I must be
fine yeah he loses too much time with
all this the night simply doesn't have a
good square here Bishop III stockfish
wants to play it's not exactly what I
find very logical its tempo when it's
it's really it's quick and ah okay now I
see the idea and that is really cool
they were it's very good idea okay I now
understand what the engine wants to do
here so if you take which looks very
normal
now you cannot go Bishop g2 s g5 wins
the night sorry
yeah so here here and it is trapped as
long as the bishop is on b2 I cannot
play g5 so let's just say I play
something else like here Anika was
Bishop g2 and g5 does not work because
the bishop all of a sudden is the most
important piece so I have to play a not
have to it it's strong to trade this so
like after this Bishop g2 doesn't work
and then you more or less have to settle
for something that you are not happy to
play like mmm yeah this for example I
can't after here black is fine okay I
went to h5 nine h4 and now I saw this
this issue with the e pawn yeah my my
point was I wanted to do this Bishop I
was expecting to play Bishop g2 I don't
know maybe he wasn't really having the
when his mind so much because g5 looks
like the knight is trapped but she's got
94 so I was thinking here castles that
was my idea at least and white castles
or now he can also take I was thinking I
would get the pawn back this way he and
I mean this is dropping he cannot keep
it but what might be better him and the
engine wants to do this
angling for long castling it makes a lot
of sense actually interesting it's very
very complex positional okay Knight G
two castles when here I'm okay I don't
really think I'm in any trouble
Queen age six engine gives Queen f5 I
didn't really think of it that much and
you kind of think okay you can do this
but it actually doesn't make much sense
him it's just a loss of time you don't
want to take on it c5 anyway
okay Knight age six yeah and again I was
operating with this idea to get a four
back but it seems like this was a four
key thought what is the big problem why
doesn't it work it's them
the G far-too-dangerous I was thinking
I'm just getting this back and okay I
was suspecting I'm a bit worse but not
like minus one point something
yeah it looks a bit looks bad if you
look at this a little bit more closely
it looks bad
yeah that's it's a lot of pressure like
if you do this this says there's this
immediate threat of the sacrifice
yeah you know you know I came when I was
a bit lucky all that so got this in f5
come with the pawn
yeah and now this is a weird sequence
before and after Bishop e6 he has no
neutrally I mean no good move he
probably has to give me the b-pawn but
it's already a little bit weird and this
is blondest house it really gives me
this sense an overwhelming position
yeah and resigns yeah that was a bit
shaky in this game more shaky than I
thought actually okay with the opening
if we that is an interesting point here
that this Bishop a3 is good okay thanks
again for watching